all right so I was embarrassed by Ryan
his superiority to me in every way was
excruciatingly painful
Ryan's recording right now yeah so I
actually practiced too trying to learn
how to solve a Rubik's Cube and I did
I'm just rambling up at the moment just
with random turns if I was hard enough
to know exactly what I was doing a
reverse engineering and that like I said
I wouldn't be doing you - where's you
gonna be an engineering shop the F up
you
yeah only person cookie okay so it's
pretty well it's good for you okay so
it's pretty well scrambled right so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to solve it
and I'm just gonna take a quick look
before I get started because regulation
think of say you can do that right right
right yes right right right yeah take a
good look at it that's a good look good
look at the cube see what move you want
to do see what side might be the best to
start off with okay right at all yeah I
treat to what I'm going to put the
two-minute clock on this one as well
it's because I want to make sure that
it's in pretty close recognition to what
it was before all the sides corner
pieces so I'm trying to get the you know
the the black which is typical the white
side in a normal routine this is a off
brand knock off rubik's cube because
right before real executed pretty cool
yeah it's turning action sucks because
it's been dropped about a hundred times
so you know thrown in a pool run in a
pool - yeah thrown in a pool twice
thrice and see it stock up moments when
I needed to go faster but now it gets
the job done
II I'm a baby
oh that one that one's flipped okay
flips
or or forward for our fabulous tricks
wait sorry backwards backwards hold that
wrong we got that thing at the top
boink boink that twice at God see it's
so crumbly it's so crumbly wombly it's
not my fault I'm making excuses already
because of a beat will be ruined baby
blend the Rubik's I am blaming the
Rubik's Cube okay just gosh okay this
Ryan's favorite yeah that's a you have
to explain things in Boop oops
yeah that's what I was like Ryan tell me
how to do it well you just gotta and
then it's done I'm like Ryan it's funny
cuz I actually did it exhale astray
there will be but yes it's done well
it's done and I did it and the timer was
a minute and 10 seconds so you know
that's not too bad Scott why do you like
that like this sound okay so I did some
did it wait wait hold this okay I
surprised you go celebrate
ah jeez I'm sorry yeah sorry I'm sorry
maybe another one another another one
another one another one another one
another one